[Musique]
les filons mesure chez renversant la
chance qu'on a de vous voir jouer en
live de vous entendre chanter pour de
vrai puis celles et ceux qui nous
regardent aussi chez eux ont bien
compris qu'on est dans une période
particulière les concerts c'est
compliqué comment est ce que vous vivez
tous à vous ça nous manque vraiment trop
là les vrais les concerts les lives
vraiment ça nous a beaucoup manqué
c'était on a fait 1 sur 15
donc c'était déjà super et non on n'a
pas trop à se projeter dans l'avenir et
tout mais tout le monde un peu dans le
même cas
on reste positif là l'avantagé avec nos
métiers c'est qu'on peut un peu créé de
celle de chez nous ça continue quoi cet
album justement était quasi prêt quand
même hein l'album pas peur quand j'ai
entendu le titre ma part je me suis dit
mais ça leur colle tellement bien à la
peau justement s'il ya bien des artistes
ont peur de rien c'est les ailes itx est
justement de sucre bah ouais carrément
avec ce que je demande à appeler comme
ça parce qu'on était flipper de nos
enfants c'est vrai c'était avant j'aime
cette image là de vous bah tant mieux
non en fait le titre été choisi par
rapport à la chanson de l'album
s'appelle pas peur on parle de toutes
les peurs que tout le monde a et en se
disant qu'en fait cette heure-là elle
est absolument minime par rapport à la
peur universelle qu'on a tous de perdre
quelqu'un qu'on aime et on se parle à
nous mêmes
toutes les trois en l'occurrence et
c'était avant le tout cette histoire de
confinement et où on a été quand même un
peu sorcière malgré-nous je crois de
l'appeler comme ça mais c'est un titre
qui est un peu une forme de catharsis
deuxième album de compos ça fait un peu
fi lle un peu flipper secourir la même
direction est ce qu'on change qu'est-ce
qu'on fait moins vrai ont flippé va
amener une précaution qui fait pas comme
ça on fonce dans le tas comment est ce
que vous faites pour travailler tous en
fond
c'est une bonne question parce qu'on
s'est jamais posé la question mais ça se
fait selon les affinités je pense du
moment du sujet chez pas de l'asbl la
presse et pas de faim c'est pas tarder
une sonorité part de ses dépens d'alex
on peut partir d'une ligne de basson à
partir d'une ligne de percu lui mettre
une image dans la nuit de peur que ça
pourrait partir de ça près comme ça ça
mais ça avait qualité pour donner une
image en gros la première résidence
qu'on a faite donc c'était dans une très
grosse maison parce qu'on était beaucoup
et tu avais une pièce où il y avait une
chanson où c'était vraiment instruments
table c'était quand on écrivait tango
par exemple ensuite une chambre on a
écrit pas le times où c'était plus
électro guitare quand j'ai déjà dit ça y
est je suis tout à fait ok maintenant
vite et n'a pas tenté d'emprunter 30 et
dimanche à la map à compter chacun je
venais passer dès que tu te sens tu es
un petit peu voilà tu as plus d'idées tu
passe à une autre champ et puis enfin
c'est vraiment ça tombe comme ça quoi
c'est à plein de personnes qui sont sur
des choses différents et en match de la
rule quoi ça et en même temps parfois on
est à table on commence à parler et puis
la taille youssoupha justement pour pas
peur qui dit venons en aux listes des
peurs qu'on a et on fait une chanson
genre on n'a pas peur en fait et il ya
des choses plus plus importante
voilà il a du coup ça avant et là on
entre à manger on commence à parler
bastien les idées brain storming hop
c'est comme ça en fait c'est vraiment ya
pas trop de règles on a bien compris que
vous travaillez dans une ambiance très
familiale il ya une autre famille aussi
qui s'est créée autour de vous c'est
votre communauté sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya quelque chose de très fort aussi
vous balancez pas mal de vidéos
ça a changé votre façon d'aborder votre
carrière d'aborder la musique battra le
truc qui est fou en fait on se rencontre
son public c'est que tout ce qu'on vient
de youtube donc c'est vraiment des
chiffres même si tu as un million en
vrai à wau c'est super et tout mais en
vrai tu peux pas te représenter un
million de personnes devant ton écran
donc le moment où on part en tournée et
qu'on fait là une première tournée en
2016 on rencontre d'autres publics
c'était en fait c'était fou enfin c'est
hyper fort de voir que les gens chantent
avec toi qui connaissent les chansons
surtout après au moment des compos là
jean tu es vraiment nos propres chansons
et en fait ça il ya forcément un partage
qui se fait enfin même en concert c'est
une énergie commune si toi tu en vois
pas et que tu reçois pas c'est vraiment
quelque chose de de partage à fond et
jeu plus tu es généreux puis le sont
avec toi et en fait c'est comme ça quoi
est-ce que vous avez vu passer le temps
les années jusqu'à aujourd'hui
franchement c'est choquant c'est en 2015
vrai nom mais je pense que tu avais fait
tant de choses des albums et concerts à
thouars la musique oui et puis surtout
au début fin en tout cas pour ma part
moi j'ai pas du tout profiter parce que
c'était tellement fulgurant qu'en fait
c'est tu te prends tout comme ça et tu
sais pas trop comment le temps parce que
c'est nouveau il faut apprendre plein de
choses sur le tas et donc en fait le
fait d'avoir tout d'un coup c'est dit et
difficile enfin en tout cas pour ma part
mais de vraiment profiter de se rendre
compte de la chance qu'on a à chaque
fois de faire telle émission où on a
joué pour la clôture du festival de
cannes des trucs vraiment improbable et
on a été vraiment très chanceuse d'avoir
fait ça on a rencontré plein d'artistes
super oued mêmes a mal tourné aux états
unis fait un petit tournée aux états
unis et on a voyagé en australie on a
fait classer un concert entre ex dirais
que non mais c'est vrai quoi quand tu
regardes on avait plein de choses mais
qui se nourrit ce qui vous reste à faire
les films par an vers son envie d'aller
passant par l'asie
l'asie nouvelles des stars de la dbs
bien sûr il ya déjà des acronymes
pourquoi pas exiger de bts voilà c'est
bon non nous reste à faire version métal
est connu en asie moi je veux faire
merci je ne veux pas mourir avant
d'avoir sa merci c'est en fait ce qui
est cool c'est que dans ce métier
en fait même si tu reviens au même
endroit que tu fais les mêmes concerts
et tout s'est jamais pareil donc
finalement même si on a déjà fait plein
de choses enfin retourner à new york
volontiers refaire des olympiens
volontiers ce sera jamais la même chose
donc en fait il ya un truc dans ce
métier parfois on me demande c'est quand
tout le monde c'est quoi votre rêve
je me rends compte que je réponds
toujours la même chose dont nous atteint
des rssi c'est vraiment moi mon rêve
c'est de faire des festivals avec des
trente quarante mille personnes
ouais mais tu l'as déjà fait ouais mais
c'est un rêve et ça reste un rêve et
c'est ça que je trouve
ouf c'est que cette même si tu l'as déjà
fait quand tu remonte sur scène tu es
encore l'acteur est en train de vivre
ouais et adresse une poule
les bons essais bouffe et entend
toujours les gens créent tu dis mais
pourquoi écrit pour pour nous là non on
est content que vous ne soyez pas
habitué à tout ça puisqu'on va vous
proposer ce à une autre échelle
ici sur le domaine de chaumont-sur-loire
dans renversant merci beaucoup les films
[Musique]